Selena you goes to supermarkets to
campaign not to shop she's the face of a
Danish initiative trying to stop food
waste you shouldn't eat food after the
expiry of the use by date and now there
is another date is called best before
and you you can actually eat the food
that is pressed the best before dates so
remember that best before does not mean
toxic after you'll grew up in Russia she
says that when she came to Denmark as a
teenager the affluent society she found
here opened her eyes to wastage I got
very upset so eight years ago I started
out a Facebook group it's called stop
wasting food and two weeks later we were
national media and today we have become
the biggest Danish organization against
food waste where 63 thousand people just
on Facebook so it's huge
we food is a store to warm eul's heart a
supermarket full of goods passed their
best before date it can't offer fresh
fish or meat instead there are lots of
frozen goods here but also vegetables
customers love the low prices the second
branch has already opened food
production puts a strain on the
environment and emits large amounts of
co2 a real turnaround would be to reduce
the amount of food produced not just
redistributed as Selena you'll also
recognizes the root cause is that there
are still a lot of food being produced
in overproduced
so basically the idea scenario is that
the we food store is closed because
there's not enough circle is produced
for the we food store still there has
been a change in mindset in Denmark if a
modest one wastage rates in the country
have fallen by 25 percent in the last
decade a personal victory for you she
traces her commitment to her youth at
the end of the soviet union
I collapsed they were food shortages in
the stores the stores were basically
empty so we wasted no food because
basically there was no food to wait to
be wasted and we had huge respect for
food you hopes to get the big
supermarket chains to start offering
rebates on single products rather than
volume discounts but above all she says
customers have to get involved in
fighting waste
I think the normal shop should be way
better at estimating how much of the
product they need so they can they can
sell it out before it goes bad that will
require Danish consumers to rein in
spending so activists like Selena Yule
are hitting supermarkets to enlist them
in the fight against wasting food